bonjour
si on va par
et la dame smith à la
et économiste écossais du xviiie siècle
il appartient au mouvement des lumières
c'était un grand admirateur de voltaire
et vous verrez par la suite que ça aura
son importance et adam smith est
généralement considéré comme le
fondateur de l'économie moderne économie
dont il a contribué à faire une science
adam smith est resté célèbre pour son
ouvrage principal recherche sur la
nature et les causes de la richesse des
nations publié en 1776 et que par
commodité nous appellerons dans cet
audio la richesse des nations
et si aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de parler
de la pensée d'un économiste c'est parce
que vous allez le voir toute pensée
économique a des ramifications
philosophique
si vous préférez un système économique
est toujours appuyé sur une certaine
vision du monde et c'est cette vision du
monde qui va nous intéresser
alors évidemment parler de sciences
économiques c'est toujours un peu ambigu
pourquoi et bien parce qu'on attend
d'une science qu'elle soit à la fois
reproductibles et prédictible la
reproductibilité la prédictibilité sont
deux critères de la science moderne
puisque c'est ça qui permet la
vérification d'une hypothèse le fait de
pouvoir reproduire l'expérience et de
prévoir les résultats de notre
expérience en fonction de certains
paramètres donnés
or il est facile de voir que pour ce qui
est de l'économie
la reproductibilité et surtout la
prédictibilité ne sont pas toujours au
rendez vous c'est d'ailleurs quelque
chose qui a été beaucoup reproché aux
économistes
au moment de la crise financière de 2008
le fait que quasiment aucun économiste
n'est vu arriver cette crise et même si
certains diront contraire le fait est
qu'il n'y avait pas au sein des écoles
économiques un consensus un avis
majoritairement partagée sur l'arrivée
de cette crise
toutes les écoles mathématiques sont
d'accord sur le théorème de pythagore
toutes les écoles physiques sont
d'accord sur la loi de la gravitation
mais visiblement pour ce qui est de
l'économie toutes les écoles ne sont pas
d'accord toutes les écoles ne prévoit
pas ne prédisent pas les mêmes
événements et c'est ça qui rend plus
difficile la classification de
l'économie dans la grande famille des
sciences d'ailleurs vous connaissez
peut-être cette plaisanterie un peu
moqueuse à propos des économistes
pourquoi dieu at il créé les économistes
pour que les prévisions des
météorologues soit prise au sérieux bon
c'est une petite pique gentil qui n'a
pas vocation à discréditer l'économie en
tant que tel car ici on ne va pas
tourner en dérision l'économie ce n'est
pas le but le but va être de comprendre
comment s'est constituée la pensée
économique moderne sous l'impulsion d'un
adam smith et surtout quelle est la
vision du monde
quelle est la conception philosophique
qui la structure car n'oublions pas que
toute science est tributaire d'une
vision du monde toute science est
tributaire d'une conception de l'univers
et que quand on comprend la vision du
monde qui préside un domaine de
recherche
on en comprend beaucoup mieux la
direction et les implications
alors comme je le disais adam smith est
considéré comme le père de l'économie
moderne et il est l'auteur d'une
expression qui a été maintes fois
reprise et maintes fois commentée dans
le champ de la philosophie et de
l'économie à savoir l'expression de main
invisible et lorsque smith parler de la
main invisible
il voulait parler de la main invisible
du marché
le marché étant le lieu de la rencontre
entre l'offre et la demande
alors au xviiie siècle le marché n'avait
pas le niveau de déploiement et de
complexité qu'il a aujourd'hui
mais disons que pour ce qui concerne
l'économie productive
les échanges de biens et de services les
principes étaient déjà globalement bien
défini et cette expression de main
invisible avait pour but d' image est un
phénomène que les économistes
considèrent comme absolument centrale à
savoir le phénomène de l'harmonisation
des intérêts
la pensée économique est fondé sur
l'idée que les intérêts privés
s'harmonisent mutuellement
alors je précise immédiatement que la
main invisible d'adam smith ne constitue
pas un concept elle ne constitue pas le
centre de gravité de la théorie de smith
c'est une simple image c'est une
métaphore est d'ailleurs c'est une
expression qui n'apparaît en tout et
pour tout que trois fois dans toute son
oeuvre dont il serait pour le moins
injuste et caricatural de réduire la
pensée d' adam smith à cette seule
expression de main invisible
de ce point de vue là je partage
parfaitement l'avis des commentateurs
qui considère que cette expression de
main invisible est souvent utilisé pour
caricaturer ou pour simplifier à
outrance la pensée d' adam smith et je
suis d'autant plus d'accord avec cette
idée que vous allez voir la pensée dame
smith n'est pas monolithique
elle ne consiste pas dans un pur et
simple éloge de l'esprit marchand elle
ne consiste pas pour le dire vite dans
une religion du marché
et le fait est que la pensée d' adam
smith a fait son oeuvre et par principe
toute théorie toute doctrine échappent
au contrôle de son auteur et finit
toujours par devenir une force autonome
si on peut pas reprocher à adam smith
d'avoir créé une religion l'économie
forcé malgré tout d'observer que ces
idées ont été les graines à partir
desquels a pu fleurir une véritable
mystique du marché
mais s'il me semble injuste de réduire
la pensée d' adam smith à cette seule
métaphore de la main invisible c'est
parce que parallèlement adam smith est
également l'auteur d'un ouvrage
s'appelle la théorie des sentiments
moraux publié en 1759 et que dans cet
ouvrage
adam smith se positionne très clairement
en faveur de l'altruisme en faveur de
l'idée selon laquelle l'être humain est
fondamentalement animé par la compassion
et l'empathie ce qui semble s'opposer
frontalement à la thèse qu'il défend
dans la richesse des nations
à savoir que ce serait l'égoïsme
l'égoïsme humain qui serait le moteur de
la prospérité et du bonheur des nations
et d'ailleurs cette ambivalence de la
pensée d' adam smith a donné lieu à ce
que certains commentateurs ont appelé le
problème adam smith problème qui
résident dans l'opposition et dans la
parente contradiction entre deux pans de
sa pensée le pan altruiste de la théorie
des sentiments moraux et le pan égoïste
de la richesse des nations
mais si j'ai estimé utile de me pencher
aujourd'hui sur la richesse des nations
c'est parce que il faut bien dire c'est
cet ouvrage qui a exercé la plus forte
influence sur l'histoire économique des
nations occidentales et non la théorie
des sentiments moraux
alors après ce long préambule pour
présenter pour contextualiser la pensée
d' adam smith
on va maintenant se pencher sur cette
expression de main invisible pour savoir
ce qu'elle signifie est ce qu'elles
recouvrent
l'idée derrière cette expression de main
invisible c'est le fait qu'il existerait
un principe d'harmonisation naturel des
intérêts privés
autrement dit que les intérêts
individuels convergent au ray
et ça va même encore plus loin puisque
le principe de la main invisible c'est
de dire que si chacun poursuit son
intérêt privé
si chacun est seulement occupés à la
poursuite de ses intérêts égoïstes et
bien sans s'en rendre compte
chacun va concourir au bien commun
une manière de résumer le principe de la
main invisible c'est de dire les
intérêts privés font la prospérité
public
alors je vais immédiatement vous lire le
passage de la richesse des nations
dans lequel cette expression de main
invisible est utilisée est expliquée par
adam smith
je cite en préférant le succès de
l'industrie nationale à celui de
l'industrie étrangères l'individu ne
pense qu'à se donner personnellement une
plus grande sûreté et en dirigeant cette
industrie de manière à ce que son
produit est le plus de valeur possible
il ne pense qu'à son propre gains en
cela comme dans beaucoup d'autres cas il
est conduit par une main invisible à
remplir une fin qui n'entre nullement
dans ses intentions et ce n'est pas
toujours ce qu'il ya de plus mal pour la
société que cette fin entre eux pour
rien dans ses intentions tout en ne
cherchant que son intérêt personnel
ils travaillent souvent d'une manière
bien plus efficace pour l'intérêt de la
société que s'il avait réellement pour
but d'y travailler
je n'ai jamais vu que ceux qui
aspiraient dans leur entreprise de
commerce à travailler pour le bien
général et fait beaucoup de bonnes
choses
il est vrai que cette belle passion
n'est pas très commune parmi les
marchands et qu'il ne faudrait pas de
longs discours pour les en guérir
donc à la lecture de cet extrait je
pense que vous avez un petit peu mieux
saisi ce qu'adam smith décrit comme
étant les vertus de l'égoïsme et vertus
de la poursuite de nos intérêts privés
c'est l'idée que si chacun poursuit son
propre intérêt il participe sans le
vouloir au progrès économique de la
société
notre manière de le dire un peu plus
direct c'est que l'égoïsme et le moteur
de la croissance économique
l'égoïsme et le moteur de la prospérité
des nations
donc là où la morale condamne l' égoïsme
là où la morale condamne le repli de
l'individu sur ses intérêts privés
l'économie va au contraire exalté
l'égoïsme l'économie va faire de
l'égoïsme une vertu
est-ce qu'il est très important de
comprendre dans cette idée de main
invisible c'est que le progrès
économique de la société n'entre
nullement en ligne de compte dans
l'esprit l'individu qui poursuit son
intérêt
et quand je dis que ça n'entre pas en
ligne de compte c'est tout simplement
lié au fait que l'harmonisation des
intérêts est un phénomène naturel est un
phénomène un personnel
un phénomène qui n'appliquent pas la
volonté des agents individuel
pour faire une analogie mme imaginer que
pour construire une maison on fasse
appel à divers corps d'artisans on fasse
appel à des maçons à des carreleurs à
des plombiers des électriciens et chacun
va s'occuper uniquement du travail qui
lui est assignée le carreleur ne va pas
s'occuper de vérifier la robustesse des
murs le maçon ne va pas vérifié que les
câblages de l'électricien soit bien
posée
le problème de chacun de ses artisans
c'est que son travail soit bien fait
et d'une certaine manière le fait que la
maison répondent aux attentes de
l'acheteur ou le fait que la maison soit
agréable à vivre pour son propriétaire
bah ça les artisans c'est pas leur
problème c'est pas leur problème au sens
où ce qui va les motiver à faire du bon
travail
c'était pas de rendre heureux le
propriétaire de la maison
parce que rendre heureux le propriétaire
de la maison ça s'inscrirait dans une
démarche d'altruisme sa s'inscrirait
dans une démarche de bienveillance
autrement dit ça voudrait dire que
chacun aurait en vue la finalité de ce à
quoi ils concourent or le principe de la
main invisible c'est que les individus
n'ont jamais en vue la finalité de ce à
quoi le concours
les agents individuel les acteurs du
marché se désintéresse totalement de la
prospérité économique de leur nation
c'est pas leur problème
leur problème c'est comment faire du
chiffre comment faire du bénéfice
c'est parce qu'ils sont animés par ce
qu'ils sont motivés par cette seule
impulsion de l'ambition individuelle
qu'ils vont faire du bon travail et que
donc ils vont concourir à la prospérité
de leurs relations
l'idée de la main visible c'est qu'on
participe d'autant plus efficacement à
la prospérité économique de la nation
que l'on est préoccupé par son seul
intérêt particulier
et c'est ça qui permet de comprendre cet
autre citation de la richesse des
nations
station extrêmement connue dans laquelle
adam smith nous dit ce n'est pas de la
bienveillance du boucher du brasseur ou
du boulanger que nous attendons notre
dîner mais plutôt du soin qu'ils
apportent à la recherche de leurs
propres intérêts nous ne nous adressons
pas à leur humanité
mais à leur égoïsme et ce n'est jamais
de leur besoin dont nous leur parlons
c'est toujours de leur avantage
autrement dit votre boucher ne fait pas
du bon travail parce qu'il a envie de
vous rendre heureux
il ne fait pas du bon travail parce que
sa motivation serait de vous faire
plaisir
il fait du bon travail parce que c'est
dans son intérêt
parce que plus il fera du bon travail et
plus vous vous adresserez à lui plus il
aura de chances de vous fidéliser
et c'est ça le principe de l'intérêt
marchand
le principe de l'intérêt marchand c'est
que plus vous faites du bon travail plus
vous en récoltez les bénéfices
et donc on en arrive à cette conclusion
paradoxale que c'est en travaillant à
satisfaire notre égoïsme personnel qu'on
contribue le mieux au bonheur de tous
donc ça c'est une idée sur laquelle on
va s'arrêter mais avant sable j'aimerais
simplement souligné le fait que cette
idée de main invisible repose sur un
principe économique très connu qui est
celui de la division du travail
la division du travail c'est à dire le
fait que chacun va exercer dans son
domaine de spécialité le fait que chacun
va intervenir sur un aspect de la chaîne
de production et que pour le dire
simplement tout le monde ne peut pas
tout faire tout le monde ne peut pas
exercer le même métier tout le monde ne
peut pas être architecte
tout le monde ne peut pas être médecin
et tout le monde ne peut pas être
plombier
donc la division du travail c'est à dire
la division des tâches et la
spécialisation comme condition la
productivité qui a été fortement
influencée par le taylorisme nos dix
neuvième siècle
ce principe se trouve à la base de la
pensée d' adam smith et c'est ça qui
fait du principe de spécialisation l'une
des spécificités de l'économie moderne
puisque jusqu'à l'époque moderne et plus
particulièrement jusqu'à l'invention de
l'industrie la production n'était pas
nécessairement considéré comme reposant
sur la division des tâches un artisan
l'antiquité ou du moyen-âge c'était
quelqu'un qui exerçait à toutes les
étapes de la chaîne de production
c'était quelqu'un qui avait un rapport
holistique à sa production
la contrat poser de ce rapport
holistique étant évidemment
l'hyperspécialisation dont charlie
chaplin nous a offert un aperçu dans son
film les temps modernes
mais si je rappelle ses principes assez
élémentaire de la division du travail
c'est d'abord pour mettre le doigt sur
quelque chose qui permet de beaucoup
mieux comprendre cette idée
d'harmonisation des intérêts c'est pour
mettre le doigt sur l'interdépendance
des agents économiques et
l'interdépendance des agents économiques
ça signifie que la somme des agents
individuel forment un système à système
étant un ensemble cohérent un tour
organisé dans lequel chacun des éléments
occupe une fonction une fonction dans
l'intérêt du système
une fonction dans l'intérêt du tout et
de ce point de vue là on peut parler
d'une vision organique de l'économie
c'est-à-dire considéré la vie économique
d'une nation comme un organisme dans
lequel chacun des organes occupe une
fonction la fonction étant orientés vers
le fonctionnement du tout et si je
prends le temps de faire cette précision
c'est pour souligner le fait qu'à cette
époque au xviiie siècle la pensée
économique et particulièrement influencé
par l'essor des sciences physiques et
notamment par cette idée que tout
élément tout âge en individuel se
définit par son action au sein d'un
ensemble cohérent pour le dire
directement les penseurs de l'époque
estime qu'il est possible de plaqués
dans le champ de l'économie les lois et
les comportements qui régissent le monde
fils
donc la pensée économique d' adam smith
n'est pas une création intellectuelle ex
nihilo
elle n'est pas le fruit du libre
inspiration qui ne reposerait sur aucun
fondement méthodologique le principe de
la main invisible n'est pas le fruit
d'une pure intuition c'est la
transposition dans la sphère économique
des lois et des principes qui régissent
le monde physique
pour comprendre cette idée il faut avoir
à l'esprit l'importance que les penseurs
du xviiie siècle accorde aux méthodes
des sciences expérimentales de la nature
sciences expérimentales de la nature
dont la physique et l'astronomie sont
les modèles privilégiées n'oublions pas
qu'au xviie siècle les progrès des
sciences de la nature ont été
phénoménaux ils sont entraînés un total
bouleversement de paradigme et c'est à
cette occasion qu on a pu s'apercevoir à
quel point les lois de l'organisation de
l'univers était aussi fine que précise
ne faut surtout pas sous-estimer la
fascination des intellectuels de
l'époque pour la formidable organisation
des lois de l'univers que la science
leur permettait de découvrir et ce n'est
pas pour rien qu à cette époque on a
assisté à une redéfinition du concept de
dieu l'image de plus en plus en vogue
dans les milieux intellectuels est en
selle d'un dieu conçu comme grand
architecte donc l'architecte c'est celui
qui travaille avec le compas et les
caire c'est celui qui tracent des lignes
et des courbes c'est celui qui a conçu
l'univers sur le modèle mathématique est
donc cette image du grand architecte
permettait de réconcilier foi et raison
elle permettait de concilier religion et
science et plus on découvre et les lois
de l'univers plus on s'apercevait à quel
point la science était efficace pour
mettre en lumière ses lois l'univers et
plus et développer le désir de
comprendre les comportements humains à
partir de la méthode et des outils de la
science et là vous allez me dire mais
quel rapport avec l'égoïsme
quel rapport avec cette idée que le
moteur de la prospérité économique
serait la poursuite de son intérêt et
bien c'est très simple et pour le
comprendre
je me contenterai de vous lire cette
citation du philosophe helvétius
philosophe français du xviiie siècle qui
disait
si l'univers physique et soumis aux lois
du mouvement
l'univers morale ne l'est pas moins à
celle de l'intérêt donc là j'espère que
vous avez bien compris ce qui est en jeu
ce qui est en jeu c'est la description
des lois du comportement humain sur le
modèle des lois du comportement des
corps physique ce qui est en jeu c'est
comprend que de la même manière que les
éléments physiques sont soumis à des
forces des forces qu'il est possible de
modéliser à travers des lois les lois
physiques et bien là une façon il est
possible de modéliser les lois du
comportement humain et la même façon que
les corps physique sont soumis à la loi
de l'attraction les corps moreau sont
soumis à la loi de l'intérêt autrement
dit le principe de toutes nos actions
la force d'impulsion qui nous dirigent
dans nos agissements
c'est l'intérêt
c'est cette force intérieure et
individuelles qui nous pousse à agir
sans avoir besoin d'être sous la
contrainte donner à quelqu'un un intérêt
à agir
et vous n'aurez plus aucun besoin de
l'obliger donné à un agent économique un
intérêt à signer le contrat
il vous laissera le stylo le principe de
l'économie moderne c'est la recherche de
l'intérêt mutuel et dans un paradigme
intellectuelle dans lequel les éléments
s'harmonisent dans lequel chacun
concourant à son propre intérêt
contribuer à l'intérêt du tout et
devient aussi nécessaire qu'avantageux
de laisser chacun poursuivre son intérêt
la loi d'intérêt mme c'est la
transposition dans la sphère économique
de la loi de l'attraction des corps dans
la sphère physique on s'aperçoit qu'au
xviiie siècle
l'analogie entre le comportement humain
et le comportement des corps physique va
encore bien plus loin puisqu'on trouve
souvent des métaphores qui comparé
l'activité économique d'une nation à
l'activité physiologique au sein d'un
organisme vivant et notamment cette idée
de la circulation des flux les veines et
ans qui permet la circulation du sang
comme les fleuves permettent la
circulation des marchandises pour
concourir finalement à la santé du
métabolisme économique
donc voyez que la persistance de ces
métaphores qui souligne l'analogie entre
le monde physique et le monde économique
en disent long sur la foi qui existait à
cette époque dans l'application de la
méthode scientifique à tous les domaines
de l'existence
en ce sens la modernité c'est le moment
où on a décidé de poser un regard
scientifique sur la nature humaine
et d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qu'on
trouvait déjà dès le xviie siècle
notamment dans la théorie politique de
ops qui postulait lui aussi que
l'égoïsme et est le principe fondamental
du comportement humain rappelez-vous
chéops c'est l'égoïsme structurelle des
êtres humains qui les portent au conflit
qui les porte à la guerre de tous contre
tous et c'est ce même égoïsme qui les
porte à sortir de la guerre de tous
contre tous en passant un pacte social
impact au cours duquel ils transfèrent
leur liberté naturelle un souverain en
échange de leur sécurité
donc on avait déjà un premier exemple de
modélisation du comportement main sur
les lois scientifiques du monde physique
c'est ce qu'on appelle le positivisme
c'est à dire l'application de la méthode
scientifique à toutes les sphères de
l'existence y compris aux comportements
moraux y compris à ce qui semble
échapper à première vue aux lois du
déterminisme physique et donc là
j'aimerais attirer votre attention sur
quelque chose d'assez amusant amusant
parce que paradoxale à savoir que c'est
par deux voix méthodologique totalement
opposées en apparence que la théorie sur
le comportement économique des êtres
humains et la théorie de la main
invisible qui en découlent se voit
justifié
en effet si vous avez été attentif à ce
qui vient d'être dit vous aurez remarqué
que la thèse de l'harmonisation naturel
des intérêts et issus à la fois d'une
conception religieuse ce qu'on appellera
la fois dans la providence divine
cette idée qu en tant que grand
architecte tu as fait en sorte que nos
comportements convergent et
s'harmonisent mutuellement mais elle est
en même temps issu d'une conception
scientifique conception scientifique
dans laquelle chacun des éléments d'un
système concours sans savoir et sans le
vouloir au fonctionnement harmonieux du
tout
donc on a ici une magnifique synthèse
entre l'esprit religieux et l'esprit
scientifique puisque dans les deux camps
on retrouve la même idée à savoir que
chaque élément en poursuivant sa propre
fin travail au fonctionnement du tout
mais en même temps j'espère que vous le
voyez cette idée selon laquelle il
faudrait laisser chaque individu pour
suivre son propre intérêt il faudrait
laisser les individus donner libre cours
à leur égoïsme cette idée entre en
contradiction totale avec toutes les
conceptions morales basé sur la charité
l'abnégation où le sacrifice
alors même que la main invisible d'adam
smith s'accorde parfaitement avec la
vision religieuse d east
elle entre en totale contradiction avec
la morale religieuse chrétienne qui fait
de l'égoïsme non pas le moteur du
comportement des hommes mais qui en fait
un vis à combattre car si l'égoïsme et
aux fondements de la prospérité des
nations et si parallèlement on considère
que la prospérité des nations est un
objectif à atteindre
alors imaginez un peu la conclusion à
laquelle en arrive
la conclusion à laquelle on arrive c'est
qu'il faut abattre les interdits moraux
abattre les interdits moraux ça signifie
simplement qu'il faut cesser de
considérer l'égoïsme comme étant un vice
pour le considérer de manière
axiologiquement neutre neutre sur le
plan des valeurs et des normes comme
étant simplement le moteur du progrès
économique
il ne s'agit pas de promouvoir le vis
pour le vice il ne s'agit pas de prôner
une religion du mal il s'agit de
considérer qu'il existe dans tout
égoïsme une contrepartie positive qui
est la prospérité économique
alors ici évidemment on sort des
préconisations d' adam smith en terme de
comportement économique c'est à dire qu
adam smith n'a jamais prescrit d'abolir
les normes morales et encore moins
d'abolir les lois juridiques qui
encadrent le comportement des hommes
dans une société adam smith ne s'est
jamais fait le porte drapeau des
comportements licencieux
il ne s'est jamais fait le chantre de la
transgression et de l'immoralisme mais
le fait est que la logique de son
système théorique conduit à cette
conclusion
et comme je disais au début de cet audio
une fois diffusé dans l'espace public
les idées échappent au contrôle de leurs
auteurs et elles deviennent des forces
autonome
en la logique d'accomplissement de
l'idée de main invisible a parfaitement
été anticipé par certains penseurs et
notamment certains penseurs du xviiie
siècle
avant même la publication de la richesse
des nations
parce qu'en réalité cette idée selon
laquelle il suffirait de laisser les
individus laisser libre cours à la
poursuite de leur intérêt et que ce
faisant on a géré dans le sens de la
prospérité économique
cette idée avait déjà été formulée par
un auteur qui l'a poussé jusqu'à son
extrémité logique qui l'a poussé jusqu'à
son point ultime de développement
cet auteur s'appelle bernard mandeville
et il est l'auteur d'un texte que vous
trouverez facilement sur internet qui a
pour titre la fable des abeilles
et quel est le sous titre de la fable
des abeilles je vous donne en mille les
vices privés font la vertu publique
la fable des abeilles mandeville nous
décrit une ruche une ruche dans laquelle
les abeilles adopte des comportements
égoïstes exclusivement tournée vers la
satisfaction de leurs vices dans cette
ruche les maîtres mots sont malhonnêteté
paraissent vol lubricité est l'une des
phrases qui résume le mieux cette fable
c'est je cite
soyez aussi avide égoïste dépensier pour
votre propre plaisir que vous pourrez
l'être car ainsi vous ferez le mieux que
vous puissiez faire pour la prospérité
de votre nation et le bonheur de vos
concitoyens
et pourquoi cette ruche et elle prospère
et heureuse malgré le comportement
vicieux égoïste de chacune de ces
abeilles
et bien tout simplement parce que le
vice créer de l'activité économique qui
engendre de la prospérité une vaste
ruche bien fourni d'abeilles qui
vivaient dans le confort et le luxe
était aux yeux de tous la mer la plus
féconde des sciences et de l'industrie
jamais abeilles ne furent mieux
gouverner plus inconstante ou moins
satisfaites prodigue de leurs richesses
et de leur vie leur force était égal à
toutes les autres ruches voilà quels
étaient les bonheurs de cet état
leur crime conspiraient à leur grandeur
et la vertu à qui la politique avait
enseigné mille ruses habile nous et
grâce à leurs heureux influence amitié
avec le vice est toujours depuis lors
les plus grandes canaille de toute la
multitude ont contribué au bien commun
voici quelle est l art de l'état qui
savait conserver un tout dont chaque
partie se plaignait ces ceux qui comme
l'harmonie en musique faisait dans
l'ensemble s'accorder les dissonances
des parties diamétralement opposées se
prêtent assistance mutuelle com par
dépit et la tempérance et la sobriété
servent la gourmandise et l'ivrognerie
la source de tous les maux la cupidité
se visse méchant funeste réprouvé
étaient asservis à la prodigalité
senoble péché tandis que le luxe donner
du travail à un million de pauvres gens
et l'odieux orgueil à un million
d'autres l'envi elle même et la vanité
et est serviteur de l'application
industrieuse leur folie favorite
l'inconstance dans l'est mais les
meubles et le vêtement se visse blizzard
est ridicule devenait le moteur même du
commerce
ainsi on constate que le vice est
bénéfique quand il était monde et est
restreint par la justice oui si un
peuple veut être grand
le vice est aussi nécessaire à l'état
que la fin mai pour le faire manger la
vertu seul ne peut faire vivre les
nations dans la magnificience ceux qui
veulent revoir un âge d'or doivent être
aussi disposé à se nourrir de gland qu'à
vivre net
bernard mandeville la fable des abeilles
[Musique]
les vices privés créés la vertu publique
parce que dans une société de la
sobriété il n'y a nul besoin de
consommer
parce que dans une société de
l'altruisme et de la générosité on ne se
fait pas payer pour nos services
parce que dans une société de
l'honnêteté il n'y a pas besoin d'avocat
et parce que si on s'en tient un produit
strictement économique
une voiture qui brûle pendant la nuit de
la saint sylvestre c'est de la
croissance
une serrure fracturé par un cambrioleur
c'est de la croissance
creusez un trou dans un trottoir et leur
boucher c'est de la croissance
est ce que montre mandeville à travers
cette fable des abeilles de manière
évidemment satirique et cynique c'est
que la vertu morale n'est pas compatible
avec la prospérité économique et que ce
qui fait marcher le pays d'un point de
vue économique ce sont d'abord novices
se sont d'abord nos penchants pulsionnel
un système économique capitaliste a tout
intérêt à ce que nous satisfaisons notre
pulsion
car en satisfaisant notre pulsion on
crée de l'activité
on participe sans le vouloir à
l'harmonisation des intérêts
râle de la fable des abeilles de
mandeville mandeville dont certains ont
d'ailleurs fait remarquer son nom
pouvait être lu man 10 weill l'homme
diable
c'est de dire que la morale et d'un
obstacle au progrès économique
eccla ruches des abeilles est une assez
belle illustration de l'accomplissement
de la logique de l'intérêt privé
j'ai signalé au début de cette
intervention qu'adam smith s'inscrivait
dans le mouvement des lumières et ça me
semble être le bon moment d'indiquer en
quoi cette information est utile pour
comprendre sa théorie de la main
invisible
les lumières sont un mouvement qui se
définit par la promotion de la raison de
l'individu et du progrès
les lumières c'est le moment de la
remise en cause des normes morales et
religieuses
issu du moyen-âge or il se trouve que
les lumières ne sont pas un mouvement
absolument monolithique
c'est un mouvement qui est traversé par
des conflits par les contradictions
sur le plan de la philosophie morale le
principal conflit auquel on assiste au
sein de la pensée des lumières c'est le
conflit entre la morale de quand la
morale déontologie sts et la morale de
bentham la morale utilitariste
or il est clair que la pensée d'un homme
smith penche nettement du côté de
l'utilitarisme en ce sens que ce qui est
recherché c'est l'intérêt du point de
vue de la prospérité
c'est la recherche de la maximisation
des richesses de la même façon que les
utilitaristes prônait la maximisation du
bien-être
si la morale du marchand telle que
décrite par adam smith s'oppose à la
morale de quand c'est précisément parce
que le comportement du marchand n'est
pas motivée par un respect de la loi
morale n'est pas motivée par une pureté
de l'intention mais au contraire par la
recherche d'un résultat avantageux
c'est ça qui fait la frontière le trait
distinctif entre la morale qu ancien et
la morale utilitariste c'est le statut
de l'intention par rapport au statut du
résultat or lorsque adam smith nous dit
que le marchand a intérêt à se comporter
de manière morale c'est à dire que le
marchand a intérêt à être honnête envers
ses clients en leur proposant une
marchandise de haute qualité qui soit en
même temps la moins chère le fameux
rapport qualité prix
mais ça veut dire que ce n'est pas une
intention altruiste qui fondent
l'honnêteté du marchand
ce qu'ils font de l'honnêteté du
marchand c'est un calcul
c'est une anticipation de son bénéfice
et c'est le constat d'une supériorité du
bénéfice par rapport à la perte
la morale de kant s'est agi par respect
pour la loi morale
la morale du marchand s'est agi
conformément à la loi morale tant que la
loi morale est avantageuse tant qu'il
est dans ton intérêt d'agir conformément
à la loi morale
et ça c'est vraiment un différend
irréconciliable entre la morale
déontologie sts et la morale
utilitariste car si le marchand se
comportent moralement uniquement par
intérêt
eh bien ça signifie que la morale n'est
pour lui qu'un instrument
que la morale n'est pour lui qu'un
levier de l'intérêt privé
et c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre
dans cette image de la main invisible
c'est cette idée d'absence
d'intentionnalité
cette absence de motivation moral
le marchand n'a pas de motivation moral
le marchand a une motivation matérielle
il a une motivation égoïste
mais d'un point de vue économique ce
n'est pas grave parce que l'économie ne
juge pas les consciences
elle juge les profits
d'appréciation économique d'un
comportement c'est le bénéfice
pas d'autres
et si l'honnêteté est un moyen de
maximiser les bénéfices alors vive
l'honnêteté vivre l'honnêteté car c'est
grâce à elle qu'on augmentera les
bénéfices
si comme le pense les libéraux l'égoïsme
et la loi de ce monde
il est nécessaire de comprendre le
caractère polymorphe de l'égoïsme le
fait que l'égoïsme à plusieurs visages
il est vrai que l'altruisme peut être
une conséquence de l'égoïsme
le simple fait de ne pas vouloir faire
subir aux autres ce qu'on ne voudrait
pas subir nous mêmes a d'une certaine
manière c'est une forme d'égoïsme
puisque c'est faire reposer notre
comportement à l'égard d'autrui sur
notre propre sensibilité notre propre
désir de ce point de vue là il n'est pas
absurde de penser que l'empathie la
compassion l'altruisme trouve peut-être
leur origine dans notre égoïsme dans ce
que les neurologues appelle les neurones
miroirs les neurones de la projection de
soi dans l'autre
dans cette idée là tous nés égaux isme
les actes les plus désintéressée en
apparence l'oubli de soi au profit de
notre prochain le sacrifice de sa vie
potentiellement tout égoïsme existe mcb
gaullisme
et se nourrir
ici
c'est l'expression de notre ego
physiologique
dans ce cas là le problème et il peut
être simplement mal posée car si
l'égoïsme peut conduire à la fois aux
sacrifices et au culte de soi
si les groupes se manifester à travers
désir d'être utile au groupe
comme il peut se manifester à travers le
désir d'exploiter le groupe
si tout peut être finalement reconduit à
des motivations égoïstes
alors peut-être le problème n'est-il pas
l'égoïsme
mais l'expression de l'égoïsme la
manière dont il se traduit dans nos
comportements savoir si nous
tous des égoïstes n'est peut-être pas la
bonne manière de poser la question
savoir si derrière chacune de nos
actions
apparemment des intéressés ne se
dissimuleraient pas un désir de gloire
de gratification symbolique d'estimé de
soi
finalement importe peu et si adam smith
a fait en sorte de nous éclairer sur ce
moteur essentiel qu'est l'égoïsme c'est
peut-être aussi pour nous dire que nous
sommes tous également coupable d'
égoïsme que l'égoïsme du boucher c'est
aussi notre égoïsme et que quitte à être
tous des égoïstes tâchons au moins de ne
pas trop leur reprocher aux autres je
vous remercie
[Musique]